[Musique]
aux portes du désert avec son fort en
majesté
jeu pour incarne toute la splendeur des
villes du rajasthan
la terre des rois dans le nord ouest de
l'inde
fondé au 15e siècle la cité mythique est
aussi surnommée la ville bleue en raison
des nombreuses maisons qui en arbore
fièrement la couleur
un camaïeu d'azur est un dédale de
ruelles
dans lequel viry chef josh y allez c'est
parti on y va sa famille vit ici depuis
trois générations
et comme tous les ans à la proche de
l'hiver il est chargé de repeindre leurs
maisons
c'est une vieille tradition ici tout le
monde pensait maison en bleu alors je
fais pareil
à l'origine ce sont les brahmanes qui
constitue la caste la plus élevée en
inde qui ont commencé les premiers à
enduire leurs murs de cette couleur pour
se distinguer des autres communautés en
peignant leur mur en bleu les brahmanes
rendaient leur maison reconnaissable le
roi pouvait ainsi les identifier depuis
sa forteresse voir où ils vivaient et où
il pouvait les trouver
cette forteresse édifiée en 1459 se
dresse sur un gigantesque rocher
ancienne demeure des maharadjahs de jo
pour elle s'étend sur 400 m de long
un palais gigantesque
aux nombreuses cour intérieure et aux
façades superbement sculpté ce guide
touristique s'est pris de passion pour
cette ancienne résidence royale
nous sommes maintenant à l'endroit où
avait lieu le couronnement vous voyez ce
siège en marbre c'est ici que ça c est
le roi la cérémonie se tenait dans cette
cour mais seuls les hommes pouvaient
assister les femmes elles devaient
cacher leurs visages alors elle
regardait depuis les balcons là haut
du haut de ses 135 m cette citadelle
constitue l'un des plus beaux système de
défense du rajasthan et a même servi de
décor à l'une des scènes d'un film de
batman
dans le film l'acteur sort d'un pluie
qui a été créée spécialement pour le
tournage c'est là que nous sommes en ce
moment quand batman sort de ce puits il
lève les yeux et ils voient ce fort
ce fort est très connu il a servi de
décor dans plein d'autres films
pour l'admirer dans toute sa splendeur
vous êtes prête c'est parti
cette touriste a décidé de se jeter dans
le vide à vingt mètres au dessus du sol
des tyroliennes emmène les courageux au
travers de ses remparts vertigineux cet
ingénieur en informatique originaire du
sud du pays
rêvait de se lancer pour découvrir un
panorama grandiose
l'a vu du fort est génial depuis la
tyrolienne on voit aussi des lacs la
ville bleue c'était vraiment super
symbole vivant d'un glorieux passé jeu
pour abrite en fait deux palais dès 1929
les maharadjahs de la ville ont
abandonné le fort pour s'établir ici
aujourd'hui bien qu'il n'ait plus aucun
pouvoir ils y vivent toujours mais une
partie du bâtiment a été transformé en
hôtel de luxe quand marc emig bienvenue
au palais c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir tout de marbre et de grès
rose il témoignait de l'opulence que
souhaitait afficher les anciens rois du
rajasthan nous sommes maintenant dans la
plus belle partie du palais que nous
appelons le dôme central c'est ici que
le maharajah a accueilli les invités
lorsqu'ils arrivaient ils se disaient
c'est tellement beau satyam
majestueuse cité bleue du désert la
mythique john pour s'accorde toujours
aux couleurs vives du ciel du rajasthan